[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link
and i'm rhett this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting link is
pulling back his curtain
uh-huh you know what's back there it's
it's a
an animal little that sounds that sounds
suggestive
yeah even saying you're pulling back
your own curtain
but this is something that pulling back
the curtain and i'm exposing my kitty
everybody has been speculating asking
questions about
of course at some point last year you
did an episode where you talked all
about the presentation the very good
presentation that your daughter lily did
in order to
uh basically ask sway us into getting
to get a cat and uh we haven't we've
hinted
at the fact that a cat is present but
this is now we're uh you're gonna let us
know all about the cat
i've been yeah we've been living with
this cat um
and i've been taking notes i've been
i've been observing
what what what is what a cat is like
what it's like to have a cat
what impact the cat has on the kneel
household
everything was in order everything that
you know well
if it ain't broke don't fix it kind of
thing but you know we have to
bring a cat into the equation and so a
lot of question marks
so i'm you know i'm on edge for my
reasons christy's on edge for her
reasons
but yes we did it
we we did get the cat uh because i'm a
lily person
you know i'm i'm decidedly a dog person
like
jade you know is i adore
that dog thought about bringing her in
today but then i didn't want to sit here
and talk about a cat the whole time and
her to get upset
she would have um so yeah i mean i i
just
i've i've spent enough time with this
cat
that i'm ready to give you a full
download on
what it's like and there's
there's still some lingering questions
okay
do you think that someone who is
thinking about getting a cat
um that this will be a useful uh
podcast for them uh i think so
yeah yeah and do you think that after
hearing your story will there be a
definitive conclusion that they will
they will come to you intend for them to
come to
well you'll have to wait and see i think
the preponderance of evidence might lead
us to a certain conclusion
but um i i'm i haven't
i'm i'm not intentionally taking this to
a certain place
as with most all of the podcasts that
i'm bringing something to the table
i'm just trying to be honest and as real
as possible about this
and then you know whatever fallout comes
from it
we'll just have to deal with there's
gonna be fallout
might be from cat lovers specifically
i've i've experienced my fair share of
fallout from cat lovers
now you've met this cat but we'll we'll
wait to
interject your meeting because i kind of
want to go in a little bit more of a
chronological order all right um
first of all i call him the cat i refer
to him as the cat
you know there's there's been this dis
you know this distant scene
that has happened it's like okay i'm in
observational mode
i feel like it's his job to win me over
um
if we're gonna have a future together
he's gotta he's gotta put some work in
too this is not just gonna be a me thing
i mean
cat's in work i'm not sure is it when
lily you know
as i went through her our response to
her presentation
one of my stipulations was i can exploit
my experiences with this cat for
entertainment purposes
in perpetuity she agreed to that so now
here i am doing that so i call do you
seek approval from your children for
any um like
if it's if it's sensitive like if
there's something in anything any
it might you mean anything that comes to
the house you oh i thought you were
gonna ask you do i seek approval
if i want to talk about my kids on the
show oh of course i i do that oh
okay but i'm just saying that if
something comes to the doors of the
house that's
not one of my kids i feel like that's
fair game to talk about on the
on the podcast like one of their dumb
friends
well and my kids got a dumb friend y'all
want to hear about it
if yeah if something comes through my
house and then becomes a part of the
house
absolutely i've gotta i gotta monetize
it right yeah and
she was on board
because she really wanted to get a cat
so i've been calling the cat
the cat when i refer to it um
it's not like the cat comes when i call
it anyway or i mean
when lily calls the cat the cat will
perk up
and sometimes come to her but doesn't
happen with anybody else but the cat's
proper name
is saka okay s-o-k-k-a
now he's a cat's given name he's an
orange
no lily gave him that name he's an
orange tabby cat and he does have
white socks his his his paws all four of
them are white
um but he was named after the
comic relief character in avatar the
last airbender
it's a person yeah he's the he's the
brother
who's he and his sister found aang the
the last airbender that's a whole other
podcast
but it's kind of related because
lily discovered that uh avatar the last
airbender was on
like they put it on netflix and like as
a dose of nostalgia she decided to
re-watch it and then orlando started
watching it for the first time
and then they just started begging the
rest of the family to watch it
saying that you know what it there's
something magical about the show you're
gonna love it
and um
i actually ended up loving the show you
know some episodes are hit hit or miss
but like
it actually is a a pretty great show and
it'll it'll catch you
it'll surprise you with the level of
depth uh so
that with the characters the journeys
that they go on the
the the character arcs the
the humanity associated with the
villains in this show
was in story structure those things were
really groundbreaking for a nickelodeon
what i'll call an anime ripoff but i'm i
i don't mean
it so it wasn't uh an anime
that was then overdubbed it with english
no
it it was uh i know that i'm even
hesitant to use the term anime because
like people define it different ways and
i
you know lincoln is really into anime so
he kind of likes
people who are really into it say anime
so okay
if you're like you're really into it but
you know what
uncle iro is is one of my favorite
characters in
anything you don't even know who i'm
talking about but maybe he's bald right
uh anyway she so being obsessed
and re-obsessed with avatar the last
airbender she named the cat
saka now i call the cat the cat and if i
don't
sometimes i'll refer to him as thomas um
which makes lily feel really weird like
i don't the things that make lily feel
weird like the way that i can mess with
her is so funny
just like hey thomas come here thomas
and then i'll like pet him on the head
it'll just like make her feel strange
because
it's just because it was the name of
your cat that you had when i was a kid
thomas was my cat it was actually just a
tomcat that roamed the neighborhood and
he would come into the
the shed behind our house and uh there
was a big pile of
carpeting and he would he would perch on
that carpeting
and i would go in there and i would pet
him you could say hey
i would say hey thomas glad i wasn't
present for that
you never met thomas i don't think so
there was also a black
female cat which we called midnight
and midnight would not let anyone pet
her another feral cat
yeah so his name's saka but i call him
thomas sometimes i don't name the feral
cats that roam my neighborhood
i don't either and i have it but one of
them came in my house remember that
walked right across my frickin couch
what do you mean oh yeah yeah yeah and
and
it got on the camera yeah that's crazy
i mean he came in my house didn't didn't
name him
i mean i don't have a good track regular
cast because thomas just disappeared and
never came back again
i got a cat just a few years after that
i was still young like in
in middle school got this little calico
cat
and i remember this my mom would let me
sl it would sleep in the bed with me
like up by my head and then one day my
mom looked and she
she said what is that on your pillow and
it was like a little worm
and i think that worm had come out of
the cat's anus
that's pretty common and so
she immediately gave the cat back like
there was no taking it to the vet there
was no i'm sure there was a very simple
fix for this it's like a classic
it freaked me out this is like a classic
80 late 80s right
sort of this is this is what happened
with when when
our pets had problems in the 80s just
give it back just give it back man just
get the cat back like now you gotta
obviously you got to figure this out on
your own and fix fix the cab but she
just gave it back
give it back to who i'm not gonna i
don't know i'm not gonna reveal it at
this point but
saka does have a problems no
saka has a problem that has not been
fixed
yet and uh it needs to happen
pretty soon and i'm gonna get to that a
little bit later
but um like i said
i i i'm i'm such a dog person
you know my main concern was
i mean i have a whole bunch of concerns
but my main concern in bringing a cat
into the house is that
how is this gonna affect jade jade is a
very jealous
protective dog you know i bring her in
here and she's like
it's embarrassing she'll like protect me
from other dogs and i'm like hey there's
not there's nothing to see here jake
just chill out
you know yeah um i didn't know if if jay
was gonna because it's like
soccer came would showed up in like such
a little kitten
i didn't know if jay was gonna eat the
kitten
or at least hate the kitten you know i i
don't know but she had
she actually did when we introduced
barbara and jade to that cat in the in
the vlog
last year jay did better than barbara
but the theory was that was because that
was a
neutral territory being at your house
so i didn't know for sure if she would
be more assertive and protective
of her own zone in her own people within
her own zone
so i was concerned about that but on the
opposite end
my hope and my vision
is that jade will love and accept this
kitten and
that they will sleep together
well like i'm going to make a new animal
i want
i i want pictures of them curled up
together in his plushy bed
okay actually you were trying to breed
them no i'm not a po
i'm not opposed to that i mean if they
hit it off that would be kind of weird
that'd be crazy
a cat dog i mean like a like a cog yeah
a debt it could happen i think a cog is
a lot better i don't think it could
happen
no i think it can't happen because a cog
or a dad neither one of those is uh
it's not a good name it's not like a lie
yeah it's like oh they got a mate
because that name is just asking for it
they're begging for it i think it might
have something to do with how
far back the lineage was uh established
evolutionarily speaking on the probably
evolutionary tree yeah it probably does
um and by the way
i got lots of photos and videos of saka
and as i'm talking about his interaction
with jade
and what i'm about to tell you and
basically everything i've got footage to
support this so
if you're just listening to this go over
to the video version on
uh youtube channel it's the airbiscus
youtube channel
hey welcome we're gonna chop i'm waving
it we're gonna chop
that thing full of soccer footage
honestly i was i was taking a lot of
footage early on
because i was documenting jaden soccer
meeting
and we i had this idea we talked about
it of
like doing a vlog on the rent link
channel
that was just about introducing socket
to the world that was an idea for a
while
yeah but then abandoning that the
footage just it just
the footage kind of grew and grew and
grew and then i didn't know what to do
do do with it well now we've got and now
i just thought this would be perfect
like a mini documentary
about your cat yeah the video version of
your biscuits we we put
we put visual aids on all this stuff so
um my main concern was the meeting and i
read up about this
okay you're supposed to put the cat in
butts first
but the butt well in a in a little crate
in a little carrier put the kitten in
there
in lily's room and then close the door
don't let jade in the room
and let the cat out of the crate and for
a few days maybe a week get used to just
that one space lily's room where she
you know where he does his business and
uh not in her closet we didn't put the
litter box in her closet
thanks for that advice we put it in
lily has her own bathroom and uh it's in
there
but getting used to that space getting
back and jade will immediately know that
there's a cat present in the house
via the smell alone so a dog can smell
man
yeah and especially when there's a big
crack under the door
you can see like a paw coming out
sometimes yeah she definitely knew
something was up
but she would sit out there and kind of
whimper and sniff and sniff and sniff
but
after a few days of that stage two was
put saka in her carry his carrier
that's the other thing is calling saka
her for the longest time
i did that because jade you're so used
to having one animal in the house after
her
you're not used to a he in the house you
put him in the little crate
and then you let jade come in and he's
protected in the crate and then jay can
inspect the cat visually
uh nasally but not actually how did that
go
jade was really keyed up and saka just
seemed
like not not too afraid
just kind of like after i mean at first
there was some nose touching but then
there was like in some cringing
but then it was mostly just the kitten
like didn't
care that much it's like very much
convinced that jay could not get to him
which was true
so there were a number of days of
bringing in the dog to sniff the crate
and the cat
in full protection but then i'm like
well we next stage is to get the cat out
and put it in a dog costume
[Music]
there's multiple steps to this and then
just let them meet each other so what
what i ended up doing was and at this
point i kind of got scared for jade i
was like i think
i think that i mean the claws on this
can hurt a dog
like could blind my dog
like that would be very upsetting to me
yeah if if if if a jade eyeball got
scratched out
because it's like how i'm going about
this so i would hold jade in my lap
i would restrain jade and then we would
let the cat
out of the crate and just kind of run
around the um
uh the room after a few days of this
eventually it was like putting them put
letting them run around a little bit
jade would jade would chase the cat
underneath the bed
and but jade was afraid to go underneath
the bed even though
she should totally be able to do that
but she wasn't
mad she was playing but she wasn't very
inquisitive
yeah like she's afraid to go under the
tail period or she's afraid to go to the
bed with the cat's in there
i think period she's
yeah she's uh she's got her she's got
her own
issues issues yeah but the cat would
i mean the cat could not just go
wouldn't go away and just cower the cat
would keep coming back out and like
giving
jade a little taste of katniss and then
going what about like the pat the pity
pat's that the cat will do with the hat
with the hand
they're really good at that just that
that eventually that eventually started
happening like a little batting of the
batting of the face my favorite thing
about cats a lot of a lot of that like
bowing up and doing the cat pose where
it's like the fur goes up in the back
goes up like
you know those like the halloween cat
pose right
or i guess you just call that the cat in
yoga
cat and cow yeah yeah no no cow just the
cat yeah just cat so
over a few weeks they got we got him to
a point that they could be in the same
room together and they just
they would jade would start and then she
would start coming out he would start
coming out of the room
and seeing the rest of the house and
jade would chase the cat
back into the room and then jade would
be happy
and then after a while uh saka would run
out
and jade would chase the cat and then
the cat would run away and then the cat
would come back
and jade would run and then it got to a
point where they're like chasing each
other all around the living room but
this is still playful
and it's well i think jade
jade saw it as as playful and i think
saka saw it
as like military training
or something you know it was like i'm
gonna engage
everything seems like training for this
cat um
how do you know that because he is a
wild beast
i mean every point of observation
for me supports the fact that this thing
is not
tame in any way i mean his pupils dilate
and they're just like totally black
like it reminds me of the cat in like
shrek
like remember when he was like his
pupils would just dilate and he'd go
into this
that makes him cute though oh he no when
he would do it it would be like
he he entered some fugue state where he
stalks around the house and
just looking for the next thing to
attack i mean
he'll he'll shred the edge of the couch
with his claws but they are
less i mean i have to believe
that a cat a current cat
is much closer to the original form of
whatever was
taken from the wild to be domesticated
than a dog is i was talking to
lily about this like it got to be wildly
different i was like
when i look at this cat lily it's
there's a part
that's like i can see a tiger in this
cat
like i don't think they're come from a
huge
ferocious tiger but when i look at a dog
the
only thing i can see is just a a
reasonably sized
wolf you know it's like it has the same
form as something that could just
i mean like a it's like a zoological
tank
that's what a tiger is man it's a furry
tank but what i'm saying is i think that
a cat
i think like a house cat is
if you go back you know fifteen thousand
years
ten thousand twenty thousand years
whatever
they'll be like cats that look like your
cat just out in the wild
think about a bobcat right a bobcat yeah
is not that different than a cat right
but jade and barbara look
absolutely nothing like a wolf that's
what i was saying
is that the difference between what was
domesticated and what we have
is so different in a dog but there
hasn't been nearly as much
there's also much not nearly as much
variety
genetically i mean i know there's like
the main [ __ ] which is like this giant
cat but just think about the difference
between a teacup like
poodle um chihuahua and a great dane
those are the same species man
but they don't have that kind of variety
genetic variety in a cat is that just
because
we haven't chosen to breed them in the
same way i don't
i think all it means maybe they're
closer to the original wild thing maybe
they're not as malleable
and that's why they can just go live in
the wild feral you if you put barbara
i mean when we put barbara outside to
pee
in our fenced fenced-in backyard which
by the way doesn't even have real grass
jesse's like you got to keep an eye on
oh you and you do have to
because a coyote cody you know mountain
lion whatever
i think a coyote would get a cat too but
i they put up as much better chances
better fighting barbara is like a
marshmallow that just rolls directly
into the coyote's mouth
one of the biggest adjustments we had to
make was remembering to close the door
behind us when we let
jade out because we escort jade out to
watch for coyotes
because your prisoner the cat is the
prisoner yes the cat
i mean if the cat got the cat got out
once
and immediately immediately darted out
the door
went to the right and then went through
a hole
and went under the house yeah just like
that right the only time that soccer's
been out of the house
it went under the house immediately and
i mean how did you solve that lily
brought out some
tinkly thing that it it was enticed to
attack
and that's what you do i mean it sees
feet as like
moving meat this if you're barefoot
this this this thing will attack and
decimate your toes your heel your
everything the cat likes to bite
everything just it's just like
it's like a killer saying you know what
i i choked him just to see what it felt
like to kill a man you know
you're putting a lot onto this cat i s
he sinks his teeth
and then the cat would eat your foot if
you didn't move it hell yeah
he would keep eating it yeah well he
doesn't eat it he likes the feeling of
his
razor-sharp teeth slowly sinking into it
the worst thing for christy it drives
her crazy
he will prowl up to her plants
look straight at her and then just
chomp down on a leaf
oh you know i mean christy's plants are
her pride and joy i saw that
i've been following on instagram and she
has come up with tried
different methods all types of
contraptions there's like aluminum foil
lying in the pots
like she's spraying i'm sure i'm sure
you're probably maybe you're at this
point in what you're gonna say but
this is like now that you're getting
into the things that the cat
does this is where i
start to think about uh
both you and christy both value
order order cleanliness and like
things not being torn up it's hard to
train a cat and a cat duh a cat
contributes negatively to
all those things like your plant
your your furniture yeah does that stuff
go away
i mean again dogs also do this but dogs
are much easier to control
so dogs stop doing it but you mean the
cat's only
still a few months old i have the answer
to your question
but first let's promote some stuff oh
go to mythical.com to get the mythical
travel mug
look at this good look there's a good
mythical morning travel mug it's yellow
it's
it's crazy looking and then you got this
one just classy looking
yeah it's just for whatever mood you're
in you know if you're in a mood that
you're just
i'm feeling a little bit cool and gray
today
i love it it's got a nice i love it too
cap
on it go to mythical.com drink your boys
um
he will scale the back of the high back
chair in our
living room like a rock climber just
like with his claws
and you know you can put tape over stuff
and like you can spray stuff on stuff
but like
he just keeps clawing at things our um
he hasn't shredded anything to death but
and
the type of fabric that we have on that
chair is the type that it doesn't show
that he's shredding it but i don't know
one day maybe we'll just see cushion
but we haven't had a lot of luck there
he just but
we have a spray bottle the main thing is
like
you know christy walks around like she's
like a she's like in the wild west with
two
too just water she's just like hit yeah
hitting him in the face and sometimes
i don't know it's he he hates it but
it's not like he runs too far
he doesn't hate it that much um
i have no complaints when it comes to
like his bathroom stuff
and credit to lily i haven't like
i haven't smelled poop i haven't seen
poop
or pee and like she's taking care of
that so he's already totally trained in
that way
yeah all of that reliably in her
bathroom
now she also feeds them in a room and
that the food stinks
cat food's worse than dog food and jade
sneaks in there and eats all of it
and then saka will sn will sneak out and
eat jade's food i think they've got a
system a little battle
well it's just more variety i'd do it um
but
watching him play with jade is amusing
that's something that i have
gotten on board with i mean they'll
they'll wrestle
like i said i mean soccer kind of thinks
it's combat training and jay just thinks
it's fun
but you know the claws aren't out but
like they're they're like biting each
other's neck
and like their hind legs and just
running around like
like really like two friends and it uh
it's good for jade because she she was
nowhere near as active as she is without
saka in the house so i think that's a
pretty
that's a cool aspect of it that i didn't
expect she's getting her exercise
she's getting her exercise in so this
this is good for jade
jade has accepted saka um to an extent
um
but i mean there's still been a lot of
adjustments
like every morning i wake up and
lily is sleeping in the tv room
because saka when the sun rises saka
will get on the bed
and just insist that lily wakes up
when the sunrise and she and like
she said that she'll like cover her put
her
put her head under the covers and like
saka will like
like dig in there and like claw at her
and just insist that she
play with it so she just leaves the
abandons her bedroom
and every single morning she she sleeps
she's sleeping on the couch
and then by the time i get up at like
6 a.m i sit down i drink my coffee
i just hear the cat just like crying in
the room
meow meow let me out let me out
let me out so i'll let the cat out and
he'll like stalk around look for
something to sink his teeth into
um but i mean
i'm i'm you know i'm trying to be even
keel about this i'm trying to look for
the things that are
somewhat positive okay i'm still waiting
okay i think i i've got something so
like i'm sitting there drinking my
coffee
in the morning and um
i'm just thinking there is no love in
this cat
it's like that like that's i i really do
want it's like i want the cat to curl up
in my lap i want the cat to receive
love and give love just just give me a
little something cat
just you know i try to pet you and it
i mean picking them up is like handling
the cactus right it's like
the the only prickly parts are on his
fingertips but if
but it he gets them everywhere and he
just wants to get down
like christy was down doing some like
yoga stretches on the ground
and then she got like her hand
got this huge gouge in it
just from doing stretches well okay like
bleeding and back in the day
and i understand why we don't do this
anymore i'm sure there are some people
who still do it but
back in the day they just took the claws
out of the cat and that's it
that's illegal i understand it's
inhumane to do that because then the cat
is not you know no longer it's like
taking a body part off of the thing you
don't want to
you don't want to do that but that's
what people did back in the
i remember they take their balls off no
well i remember back it's a little
different well but taking their balls
off contributes to less
yeah just you know cats needing the home
um you know you know bob barker you
remember that
but i remember growing up if somebody
had a cat
they would specify and maybe this is
just in my mind but
it'll be like he's still got his claws
like careful he's still got his claws
as opposed to all the other cats that
don't yeah
you know what i mean and it's like now
you can't even you can't even do that
i'm not advocating that you should
but my question is
earlier which is i wish he didn't have
claws naturally
but no but is um
if you because or teeth because people
can be cute because people have like
the the you know the carpet tower
cat things we have a couple of those
but do they is there a way to train them
and the way they should train a dog to
be like
you can do your claw stuff on this but
you can't do it on this
or is is that are you gonna i refuse to
be the one to do all the research
okay but i'm like lily you you need to
figure this out you need to figure out
how to train this cat like chrissy's
doing research to protect her plants
she'll probably get to these answers but
you know i i can only be
if i start researching it then i then
everyone starts looking to me is the one
with the answers you know
you don't all the cat people listening
are like you gotta dim it
guys i can tell you all this i'm sure
it's i'm sure it's just simple
just google it but it's important to me
to not have to be
the guy who's training this cat and
honestly i would rather have some some
plants and some furniture messed up a
little bit than me to have to be the
it guy so to speak you know oh can you
fix my email
how has you fixed my cat now how has
this impacted travel
because obviously we haven't really done
much travel next time we travel
but what what is it we're not gonna
bring the cat but okay so you just take
it to a boarding place
or get somebody to come as he gets older
get somebody to just come by
because they can just kind of camp out
by themselves yeah he's probably happier
that way anyway
um the only way you can
really give the cat love is if he's
asleep
if he's curled up in a place one way
thing you can like
you can pet him and then he'll keep his
eyes closed and you know you can even
pet his his chest and his stomach like
because i'm trying to train him to let
us pet him everywhere
now when we've talked about we've talked
about this aspect of cass before
many people have pointed out with me
uh that cats actually are for people who
have more like
self-confidence or whatever and are less
needy and less narcissistic
because dogs give you that love yeah but
cats don't but then other people have
said cat no
my cat i can't remember when we said
this but we talked about cats not being
as loving as dogs and then all of a
sudden
everybody started tweeting everybody has
an affectionate cat all the affectionate
cats that wanted love from them
so is it that your cat can grow to be a
loving cat i hope so or is it that your
cat is just a demon cat
and it will always be a demon cat and
some cats are not like that and it's
just on average more dogs
are you know give more attention to
humans than cats
rarely in the morning again if i'm
drinking my coffee i let him out of his
room
he's stalking around looking for
something to kill
after a few minutes of that he'll he has
hopped up
on the couch beside me and
like inspected the couch next to me
and i notice he's purring
and i'll like i'll rub his head that
means he wants to eat you right but he
won't come sit in my lap
i i can tell he likes it but i can also
tell that his true passion is finding
the next thing to kill
so i'm like i'm i'm saying look doesn't
this feel good don't you like this like
right right here like his his jawline
like he loves to be petted right there
and like
the you know the purring is such a tease
because
i'm fascinated by it like it's so
calming to me
i'm drinking my coffee like i'm petting
this animal and it's like
it's releasing this this
vibratory hum that
is just i just you know what if i could
change one thing about jade give her the
purse i wish he could purr
like that's the one thing i've noticed
i'm like man
jade needs that upgrade you could
probably get that installed in beverly
hills
there's probably that option it's kind
of like a pacemaker for a dog
it's like it like a like the vibration
they can do they could go to anything in
a mobile phone you just put that in the
dog's larynx
or something i don't know i don't know
what makes it
like how do cats purr man it's it's
fascinating so we could also google that
no
let's not let's just speak into a
lecture about it well i think it might
be magic
is it like is it like a friendly old man
making tea like uncle iro making his tea
and he's like humming to himself
you know it's is it that is it a cat
humming a song well in my experience
they always
they've always seemed somewhat content
when purring
so if it feels like it might be like
that kind of thing i mean
it's but does it feel directed to you
yeah yeah it kind of did because like he
came up on the couch
he's he's when he gets when i'm petting
him the
purr increases a little bit and
there's nothing snapping let me just
it's not perfect let me just take a
little aside to say that
for everybody who said that as a dog
person all that means is that i'm just
more needy i'll just say
you're right i mean like that's why
we have a dog we have a dog for the
companionship that the dog
provides we have a we have a dog for the
joy that the dog breaks it makes me so
happy
when she insists on being with me and i
sit down
on my couch and barbara jumps up and
then jumps up and then looks at me
yeah and if i don't look at her if i
don't make eye contact with her
touching her she's like she's mad at me
[ __ ] she'll she'll start barking
growling she'll take her hand and
she'll take her hand first thing she
does she takes her hand and she puts it
on her head to
show me what she wants on her own head
yes and then if i don't do that she
takes her hand and puts it on my hand
or takes her whole face and puts it in
my hand and i love this
it brings me joy there's a serotonin
boost now i'm not saying that cats don't
do that
people have shown me evidence that their
cats do do this but i don't think
there's anything wrong with wanting that
from an animal oh
don't be don't be defensive i wanna i
fully admit that's why i'm a dog person
because they're more reliably into me if
a dog could purr
it would all be over well that's where
the cog comes in and i think we could do
it
i think i think it would i mean but
enough resources that purring thing is
just
it's magical man it's like
i mean it's it's like having a like the
massage setting on your
on your recliner but it's a living being
that's like well he's not in my lap yet
but like
i wanted to be there eventually well
speaking of eventually i i i'm
interested in
this dynamic that's developing which is
um
i mean first of all i'm sure all the cat
people are going to tell us that
things are going to get better for you
and the cat's going to chill out as it
gets older or whatever
probably right but i think so um
lily is going to college next year she
thinks she's taking this cat with her
and i just don't what college is that
where you take a cat with you yeah i
don't
i don't i don't know we don't know where
she's going you know can't keep her
college we're starting to
we're starting to get letters of
acceptance from different places
uh but yeah it's we don't know it's too
early to tell
but i just yeah i i i'm assuming you
can't take it
dormant the cat is not going with her
and i told her that i was like
listen this is a decision you're gonna
sink
on to college i have to assume this
cat's gonna be part of
our lives and she's gonna come back home
and say oh i miss you so much but i
abandoned you to college and didn't
think about
and then really when she graduates
college or when she gets an apartment
in like the last two years of college
then she'll take the cat back with can
you believe i have i mean that we're
even having this conversation
that i have a child that's this fall
is going off to college yeah i mean i
can't wait for my kids to leave the
house it's
crazy just kidding but they don't
my kids don't have a cat so it's
different yeah she did this to us
yeah she she tricked us into this and
used the like this whole pandemic
dynamic
it's like you know everybody got a
little bit weak
jesse has really been pushing for dog
number two i don't know and i know that
you guys
we've both been talking about dog number
two for a really long time and jesse
is constantly showing me pictures of
other dogs and i
love dogs but i also think about
just the added responsibility and uh you
should do it
give give barbara a playmate it i mean
even with soccer that's that's such a
great thing for jade it's like it's good
she's healthier she's she's engaged
she's off the couch you know i don't
feel as guilty about giving her
giving her walks anymore you mean not
giving her walks
yeah that's what i meant sakin can do so
many things that
jade can't and i'm trying to you know
the only way i can really enjoy saka is
the purring
trying to convince her that i'm worthy
of
his love that doesn't feel good but just
being able to observe
this wild animal in my house i'm just
trying to embrace that as kind of cool
he watches tv you know jade
in in the in jade's lifetime i've only
seen
jade watch tv like twice and it's
it's so strange it's like two times in
like all these years like
look jade jade was i mean there was a
dog barking on television now she's
looking at it for a second but like
she never watches tv barbara's the same
way and this is not i
first of all i i watch enough instagram
videos to know that there's lots of dogs
and cats that watch television and make
real connections with the things on the
screen
but i can like if if i'm not with jesse
and we're facetiming and barbara's with
her and you talk
and then i talk and jesse's putting my
face right here he's the barber voice
it's like it's like i don't exist uh
jade will respond to that if i am
in if i'm in two dimensions i do not
exist in barbara's mind
jade will hear my voice and respond to
it but she won't
connect with the screen i think it would
be a hologram would work
sockable i mean i mean soccer will watch
if you if you put like a you know the
whole laser pointer thing
or even if light reflects off your watch
onto the wall
he's going to attack that so again he
watches tv jay doesn't do that
you know how in my hallway when you're
walking down the into like the tv room
there's that one step up because like
where my
stairs come down it the stairs don't
time out correctly so there's like one
whole step up
area in my hallway so if you were
running at top speed you could trip
because you have to step up and then
back down into my tv room
jade once it gets dark
jade will if we're all in the tv room
she will will hear her whimpering and
she'll be
four feet in front of that one step
and she is afraid to walk up that step
and come in the tv room so she's in the
hall and she's afraid to go up the step
and then down into the tv room
yes it's like a barrier and i it's like
a cow and like a
cow fence or something she i think she
sees it as a big hole or something
that's my theory
so i'll go in there and i used to pick
her up i bet you know i babied her a lot
oh yeah really yeah but i've stopped
doing that and i go behind her and i use
my foot and i like
i nudge her in the butt and make her
skid
all the way up to that step and then
jump over it
saka on the other hand just kind of
walks over it
yeah which is kind of normal something
else that she does it just
that's not i'm not impressed jeff oh
you're not impressed i think that's more
of a jade deficiency
how about this so this could come as no
surprise jade will not walk up the steps
to our bedroom on the second floor
well that's because she's seen things
soccer will
i'll be in my bedroom brushing my teeth
or
whatnot i like sometimes i like to walk
around my bedroom but
go out of the bathroom into the bedroom
sometimes yeah i just
brush my teeth in the and the cat's just
walking around up there how did you get
up here oh yeah
you walked up the stairs because you can
do that
yeah that's not wow that's normal um
you've mentioned two things that are
just normal he he can open doors
okay i'm listening pretty impressive now
big heavy doors
some of them they're old and they don't
latch so he he doesn't jump up and like
turn the knob but a lot of them don't
latch and he will sit there and like
he'll push his way into rooms through
doors
jade would never think about doing that
he so i'm saying he opens doors james
just might be a little
how do i put this what is a good word
for this
perfect uh dumb
jay's not dumb jade's timid man you
don't you
okay all right she's timid okay that's
what it is i mean part of it's my fault
because like because she's
part wiener dog i was real fixated on
not hurting her like
vertebrae in her back so you're not
supposed to let a wiener dog jump down
off of couches or beds but she's not
really that long
she's not so i don't know she's gonna
have that many problems she probably
wouldn't but
i was still so concerned about it that
like i wouldn't let her run down the
steps and so i would pick her up and
carry her upstairs and
carry her downstairs you did it but the
one step i never carried her over the
one step that
she just kind of extrapolated into
steps are dangerous you talk her steps
are dangerous but it's kind of good
because now
i can keep her in places this cat you
cannot keep this cat
anywhere it's just
it's too much the main problem with saka
before you get to the problem he's not
stupid what you just said though
it sounded like so you started you said
things saka can do that jade can't
and it was like and what was i supposed
to think about like what was
isa what were we supposed to think about
that like oh okay
cats are is this a competition i don't
what am i supposed to
i'm trying to i'm trying to like observe
and appreciate
you're trying to love this cat i'm
trying to love the cat man
i'm trying to okay but but what if the
cat will never love you
i think it's because of his testicle
okay here we go
he's got one he's only got one
there's only one we can see and we're
pretty sure there's another one this is
like a nfl kicker
i bet he could kick a mean field goal
this is an inside joke
and i don't know how many of you who
grew up when we grew up
thought this but like we were told by
someone and this
spread far and wide in our circles that
nfl kickers had
one testicle removed for flexibility
purposes
just to be able to get that leg back and
forward
let's get it way up there and i was like
man you know what it's a serious job
i guarantee you they would be willing to
do that the only i mean you got two it's
redundancy anyway i mean
you know the phrase i give a left nut to
be a nfl
kicker is not it's it's just it's rooted
in reality has an
origin right yeah uh it they
in college it's outlawed they had to
crack down on it
yeah yeah yeah but you have to be a
professional you have to be getting paid
to kick a football to to have a testicle
removed
right a lot of people and there was that
one guy who got
he in getting ready for the nfl draft he
like
he had one more year of college but he
wanted to go into the draft and he
you know he got his testicle removed and
then he was like
but it was a little longer right yeah
the ncaa cracked down on him
right and then he was he was he was left
in a lurch because he didn't get drafted
couldn't kick the final year
thought he would get away with it but
you can you can tell
you can just use another because it's a
few inches of flexibility like that guy
must oh he's got he's missing a ball
plus if you
look where the testicles are yeah
sometimes if they're like
if they're like you know that little
thing that holds the football
the tea the tea yeah you know when the
in the college people use the tea
and they bend over to pick up the tea
that's when you look at yeah that's when
you can tell that's when you look at
their testicles to see if there's two so
your cat is going to be a nfl kicker
the other time is this a problem you're
going to cut you're going to get rid of
it anyway
i think his what i think is that the
other testicle is up there it's just
afraid of him
um
his ball hasn't dropped man can i tell
you something real quick i had
there's a video i got to show you now
that you're talking about testicles
dropping
i saw this video of this bit afraid i
saw this video of this
bull how on instagram
oh god and this bull's balls oh
we're hanging so low what that it was
swinging around and he was having to
like step
weird to like avoid stepping on his own
balls
[Laughter]
i gotta show you this video i don't want
to see it his balls had
fully dropped oh wow they were about to
drag
it's
[Laughter]
yeah we took him to the vet and we said
listen this
this cat is out of control please tell
us that
they can't remove the balls until they
drop or unless they
and after a certain time of them not
dropping first of all you got to remove
the balls
before they turn a year old and we're
well within that because they can go
pollinate somewhere yeah it becomes it
becomes a problem with them like
spraying or whatever i don't know i'm
talking about sex
i'm talking about the actual act of sex
it will go have sex with something and
make another cat
i know that but i'm saying there's also
like the cats will spray
i don't even know what to say i don't
know man i don't want to know that's why
i got it you don't know anything not
about cats man i don't i
i know i'm telling you everything i know
and it's a lot i've talked for freaking
50 minutes about everything i know about
a cat yeah right
i think half of what i said is so
trope-ish because that's what i've
learned oh the cat people are so mad
at both of us cats are just tropes man
they're just
stalking tropes that's all they are yeah
but i wanted to love me but i think the
balls have got
to drop and be removed or we got to
we're
we're going to schedule them for
exploratory surgery to go up in there
coax the second one down and then take
them both off
and he should mellow out some wow
that is our hope you gonna video that
uh i could
i don't think i will though i was just
asking i'm not going to
no okay good i wouldn't watch it anyway
yeah you would i mean when when the
when the the bull ball video comes up
i'm not going to watch it it's not that
great don't reach for your phone
if it just comes across your instagram
what's wrong with you man
uh oh look what is that it's a comedian
i follow that
does voice tony baker who
look at this man oh my gosh
wait look he said oh my gosh look look
look at that
it looks like what on earth it looks
like two baseballs
in a pantyhose oh my god that's like
that's a butter sock man you know what
you know about a butter sock
no my kid my kid's talking about a
butter tony baker is saying something
very funny about it
shout out to tony baker double butter
sock happening down there underneath
that bull man
shoot so anyway that's what can happen
with testicles i knew you were gonna
make me watch it
man i'm gonna i'm gonna be going to bed
tonight i'm just gonna see that thing
dangling
i don't know man i i i want to love the
cat
maybe the balls will make a difference
i'm sure it will only help
the cat will mellow out over time
here's the thing sometimes i did i i
have a ray of hope because
sometimes he and jade
will lay down in the sun on the slain
same floor mask like the lion and the
lamb
they're not touching they're not in the
same bed yet
but they're enjoying the same patch of
sun and that gives me a little bit of
joy
what kind of friends can i just tell you
how i think this might end
um this is anecdotal of course based on
my experience
um in families where there is a cat and
a dog
or any combination of numbers of cats
and dogs okay
uh it seems not to be uncommon
that there comes a time
in which people seem to have a
fruitful loving affectionate
two-way relationship with the dog who
they refer to
by a name and then the cat
they refer to as the cat
yeah the cat does whatever the hell the
cat wants to do right and the cat is not
really in an emotional relationship with
the humans or the dog
it just is kind of around it's a round
yeah
that again anecdotal i don't know if
this is representative
of the reality the general reality
but it seems that those families are
perfectly happy and it seems that
yeah he'll just the cat is perfectly
happy he'll move to the fringe of our
society but it is a
it is a it is a distinctly different
thing
in those scenarios i know that there are
cats that are exceptions to this rule
i've again
i've been tweeted many of them but what
i'm asking you
is that if that is what is in your
future okay
how do you feel about that
it could be worse you know i think
there's
i it's not what i'm hoping for but it's
not what i'm afraid of
i could i could be fine with that but
what if it's more about by the way
it's not going to keep us from getting
another dog
because that's chrissy's also looking at
a bunch of dogs and sending me pictures
and
said i think this cat could move to the
fringe and then especially if you get
another dog i mean then it's there it's
it's outnumbered
oh yeah and it's like okay i see the i
see the writing but the k
but but i'll i'll call him my name saka
likes jade and when when one of them
gets up
the other one when the jade gets up late
jade sleeps late jay gets up
and immediately looks for soccer and
they you know they are friends it's
working
you know so i don't i don't think we're
going to that french territory yet and i
think hey
let's get these balls behind us and then
maybe the
maybe some purring won't enter my life
but what if the purring isn't as good
after the balls are gone
what if the balls have something to do
with it um you thought about that and
also
different questions i have not heard
that would anyone do you get to keep the
balls like in a jar
oh yeah like a rabbit's foot really make
like a necklace out of them
or at least earrings i mean that would
work i mean i have noticed that the ball
sack
is very furry
they don't cut the ball sack off oh they
i think they do
yeah because then you just got this like
empty sack dangling back there i don't i
don't think
i've never seen a cat with a with just a
flat
i think if there's not balls in there it
kind of just sort of reabsorbs itself
you think they sucked but i will film it
okay
i'll i'll just if i i i know you're into
this having
never done uh i didn't get into cats
start with the balls never done this
kind of surgery before or even thought
about it i've never done surgery of any
kind
never had surgery done on me but i think
they cut the sack man and then they
suture this well i know that in the case
of a bull
a lot of times what they'll do is
they'll you and your bull balls they'll
put
like a rubber band of some kind above
them
and then the balls just fall off i mean
again that could be like the nfl kicker
thing that could be just
that bull you showed me doesn't need a
rubber band he could use a whole like
pvc pipe how many times does he
accidentally step on his own balls
like that i mean just in that one like
seven second clip he almost stepped on
his balls at least three times
you're gonna make kiko put this in the
in the video version
no i'm not you can go you no you can
find it do it kiko we don't care put it
in there
no don't don't the bottom line is man
saka makes lily happy i don't know why
or how but he does and you know what
like i said at the beginning i'm i'm
ultimately
i'm a lily person and
i will hopefully win this cat over
and then maybe it'll be more of a
connection to lily when she's off at
college i don't know maybe
you know there's something to that well
i think maybe one day
the cat is going to
[Music]
you're going to leave the door open at
the time you don't mean to
don't the cat's gonna get out and then
and then
sometimes it's gonna pass it might be
hours and might be days
and the cat's gonna come back and it's
gonna have something in its mouth
bird mouse gopher
bull ball sack potentially and it's
going to place it
at the threshold of one of your doors as
an offering to you
and that will be when it has determined
that you are
it's god and at that point
that's what we're after you get the love
that you're after that your ego needs
yeah and until then maybe i need to play
more hard to get yeah yeah yeah
don't be too obvious i bet you i could
train jade to purr i think i could think
about if you were trying to get
a person interested in you that didn't
seem
interested seeming pathetic
and seeming like a tryhard isn't gonna
do it i think you've got to be subtle
and i think you've got to play the cat
game i
what have i told you about my actions
that you're now describing as pathetic
and try hard i just pet the cat when
it's sleeping
you seem a little too into the purring i
would keep i would play that closer to
the vest
[Laughter]
okay you know i i think we're in this
for the long haul unless we get
you know my my in-laws well i i mean i
can't tell that story it's too cruel
right they lost a cat yeah yeah i'm not
it's a
it was a strange circumstance it's a it
would be funny in a book written in the
50s
you know what i'm saying it's that kind
of humor right
okay oh my gosh well you know what
let's let's give a wreck it's your turn
to give a wreck uh
you know sometimes i like to tie these
things in thematically to what
we talked about but i i guess i mean you
did talk about how your cat sees
everything is meat
okay uh as i like to do
in giving culinary related
recommendations my
recommendation this week is the
thermapro digital instant read
thermometer
not a sponsor oops no internet i try to
click on it this thing is uh
well i can't it's not it does it's just
thermometer
this thing costs less than 20 bucks i
want to talk to you about the importance
of having a meat
thermometer right it's especially these
instant read ones i'm not talking about
one of these ones that you just
stick in there and you wait this thing
so i got i got one yeah i use it
so i'll do my uh um
you know you can't assume that one steak
or one burger or one piece of chicken is
representative of
all pieces of chicken you gotta if you
got to get every one of those to the
correct temperature and this little
handheld instant read thermometer
that felt like i said that weird it's
super easy to like manage most
multiple pieces of meat and i when i do
my my hot chicken and i'm
frying like you know 12 14 thighs don't
want to eat i don't want to overcook
anything period
you can't make assumptions man you let
the robot do the work
i mean yes i know your grandma didn't
use one of these and she went by her eye
but that's why your grandma had dry ass
chicken you know what i'm saying
so the meat the meat guys who talk about
this stuff they're they're all pro
thermometer even the um like the
charcoal that i buy
like high dollar charcoal it it tells
you that you get you know
get a good meat it's a piece of
information that will help
with the final shame and it's what i'm
saying and it doesn't make you a sucker
it makes your meat better so anyway it's
and this is one that has worked for me
i've got two of them
just here's my here's my piece of advice
though
don't accidentally put it on celsius
and then cook to that yeah that would be
165 degree
chicken i don't even think celsius i'm
not sure you can not even possible but
if you're waiting for that
it probably is possible you're going to
burn your chicken
and i've i've been baffled a few times
it's like damn i thought this was i knew
this was done and it's like oh i gotta
toggle the fahrenheit
and let me just say this does not
replace the thermometer that you leave
in the larger pieces of meat
i don't do like a pork butt and do the
instant wreath
your mom advice about that don't eat
that make sure you take it out of the
meat before you eat the meat
and do not trust pop out thermometers
and turkey breasts
those don't work they're not reliable
now we're in rant territory okay
are you just any meat thermometer or
that one specific the therma pro
not a sponsor is i think it might be
amazon's choice and that's probably why
i got it but it's you know it works
it works for me not a fold-out pro yeah
it's orange it's easy to see
led backlight when it's dark out there
in the grill yeah it's got a light
button you got to have it all
hashtag your biscuits let us know
y'all cat people going to come out of
the woodwork and school us
please be gentle with let's do it we
like that engagement treat us like a
ball of yarn okay
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best